[Musica]
buonasera se possiamo andare con allora
guardate questa è la mia diapositiva
preferite fa vedere quanto stiamo
crescendo e con che velocità stiamo
crescendo
questa è la popolazione dell'homo
sapiens eravamo 3 miliardi nel 1960 dopo
poco più di 50 anni siamo già 7 miliardi
e 7 probabilmente saremo oltre 10
miliardi entro il 2060 venne immaginate
l'impatto che già abbiamo ma che avremo
nei prossimi anni sul nostro pianeta
un pianeta che si troverà vedere ancora
di più ridotte quelle sono quelle che
sono le aree dove noi ancora non
interveniamo pesantemente per drenare
risorse quindi immaginate che cosa
significa per la terra sopportare una
popolazione così ampia
ora tra il 1970 e 2014 noi abbiamo perso
oltre 60 per cento degli animali e
prevediamo di perdere decine di migliaia
di specie nei prossimi anni
già in questo momento abbiamo decine di
migliaia di specie tra cui il 25 per
cento dei vertebrati che sono a rischio
di estinzione e il 13 per cento degli
uccelli
ora che cosa possiamo fare non stiamo
frenando la nostra crescita
possiamo però cercare almeno di
salvaguardare la biodiversità in queste
archi e che non sono l'arca di noè ma
sono delle arche che rappresentano dei
grandi congelatori dove noi cerchiamo di
tenere un po della biodiversità cercando
quindi di salvare qualcosa che ci
ricordi la biologia la storia evolutiva
di tante specie che oggi ancora magari
riusciamo a vedere ma che fanno per
scomparire nei prossimi anni e come
facciamo come funzionano questi sistemi
di ar che funzionano cercando di salvare
in grande banche dati quelli che sono
informazioni che abbiamo facendo foto
delle specie che stanno per scomparire
congelando alcune cellule perché si
possa avere un giorno la possibilità di
studiare meglio il loro contenuto a
livello di anea e cerchiamo di
sequenziale cerchiamo il sequenziale
così da riuscire a leggere qualcosa
riguardo a quello che è il sistema
operativo di queste cellule quindi
cercare di capire qualcosa di più su
quella che è la biodiversità genetica e
sequenzialmente negli ultimi anni è
migliorato tantissimo
come potete vedere da queste diapositiva
solo nel 2001 sequenziare un essere
umano è costato 3 miliardi di dollari ci
sono voluti 13 anni la tecnologia
funzionava ma non si poteva permettere
di sequenziare ciascuno di noi abbiamo
capito in quegli anni l'importanza di
leggere il dna degli esseri umani per la
prevenzione delle malattie la diagnosi e
molto spesso anche la cura per cui
abbiamo cominciato a cambiare quelle che
sono le metodologie sviluppandone di
nuove e riuscendo a ottenere già solo
dopo 10 anni lo vedete siamo riusciti a
costruire dei sequenziatori che sono
stati in grado di leggere il dna di non
essere umani soli 15 giorni a una cifra
tutto sommato modestissima 20.000
dollari e vedete come solo dopo altri
sette anni noi siamo riuscito a
sviluppare delle tecnologie che ci
permettono di sequenziare il genoma
umano in un solo giorno e con meno di
2.000 dollari
ora se ci pensate bene questo è un trend
che ricorda un trend che abbiamo già
visto nella nostra società negli ultimi
nell'ultimo secolo che è quello
dell'informatica
ora pensate alenia che il primo computer
1947 180 metri quadrati di spazio
occupato 30 tonnellate di peso
centinaia di kg va di corrente consumati
per fare delle operazioni molto semplici
e dopo meno di 35 anni
arriva il primo personal computer e
primo personal computer ha impattato in
modo devastante in senso positivo sulla
nostra società perché per la prima volta
ci ha dato la possibilità di scrivere un
pensiero salvarlo richiamarlo in memoria
modificarlo stamparlo risalvato
fino a quel giorno usavamo la macchina
da scrivere l'unico sistema che avevamo
per trasferire informazioni a distanza
era il fax che era stato inventato da
pochi anni non avevamo nessun l'altro
oggi ci troviamo invece che i personal
computer sono ci sono potenziati
tantissimo abbiamo una tecnologia che
adesso è assolutamente mobile
abbiamo dei telefonini che vengono con
noi e che ci permettono di fare
qualsiasi tipo di calcolo di salvare
qualsiasi tipo di documento e di
interconnettersi con il mondo fino a
prima degli smartphone noi per
interconnettersi con il mondo dovevamo
andare o in ufficio a casa per stampare
un documento scrivere un documento
dovevamo andare o in ufficio a casa
adesso abbiamo la possibilità di portare
con noi quella tecnologia e sono diversi
anni che io da genetista mi rendo conto
che in questo momento non stiamo
portando all'interno dei laboratori di
sequenziamento dei campioni che vengono
da fuori
quindi che siano pazienti malati che sia
biodiversità
noi prendiamo i campioni li portiamo in
laboratorio erano anni che cercavo di
fare questo cambio di paradigma e
portare il laboratorio laddove sono i
pazienti
laddove sono i campioni ecco questa
scintilla una scintilla che è esplosa a
quattro anni fa quando nel marzo del
c'è stata una conduzione una
congiunzione astrale però è molto
favorevole
due cose un sequenziatore che era un
prototipo un sequenziatore piccoletto
come quello che vedete è questo qua a
quell'epoca funzionava ancora piuttosto
male ancora adesso non è perfetto però
questo è un sequenziatore costa 1.000
dollari è portatile si attacca un
portatile attraverso un normalissimo
cavo usb 3 e poi la seconda
secondo accadimento di quell'anno è
stato l'aver incontrato michele menegon
michele menegon e un biologo
evoluzionista del museo il museo di
trento che si occupa di biodiversità
tropicale michele va in giro per
l'africa a caccia di nuove specie di
rettili anfibi e quell'anno mi chiese se
avesse voluto accompagnarlo con lui in
una delle sue spedizioni e gli disse sì
io posso cercare di venire con te a
patto che andiamo a caccia di anfibi non
andiamo a caccia di rettili e posso però
cercare di sviluppare un laboratorio
portatile che gira intorno che ruota
intorno a questo piccolo sequenziatore e
cercare di fare quindi una cosa che
nessuno ha mai fatto prima
portare un laboratorio di sequenziamento
del dna in mezzo alla foresta in
condizioni ambientali veramente
difficili sviluppando però delle
tecnologie che a quel momento ancora non
c'erano per cui abbiamo impegnato circa
un anno abbiamo avuto la possibilità di
lavorare all'interno della serra
tropicale del muse
quella che vedete le mie spalle appunto
la serra ea condizioni di temperature
umidità che sono molto simile a quella
della foresta tropicale in cui saremmo
andati dopo e li abbiamo provato a
validare tutte le procedure che in un
anno abbiamo messo a punto in università
a verona abbiamo dovuto costruire
strumenti che fossero in grado di
funzionare a 12 volte perché mezzo alla
foresta l'energia elettrica non c'era
abbiamo dovuto risolvere dei problemi
fondamentali il trasporto dei prodotti
chimici e non qualsiasi laboratorio voi
avete i freezer noi lavoratori abbiamo
freezer che vanno a meno 20 che sono gli
stessi congelatore che abbiamo a casa e
poi abbiamo dei feriti che arrivano
addirittura a meno 80 abbiamo materiali
che viaggia in ghiaccio secco non
avevamo la possibilità di portare tutta
questa tecnologia però all'interno di
una foresta
abbiamo dovuto sviluppare dei protocolli
che ci permettessero di arrivare almeno
in una serra tropicale a sequenziare il
dna di quella rana che stava all'interno
di quella scatoletta e poi da lì è
dimostrato quello quindi dopo 12 mesi di
lavoro siamo partiti e siamo abbiamo
voluto provare a dimostrare che il
laboratorio avrebbe funzionato anche in
una vera foresta tropicale e siamo
andate in tanzania in questo posto
fantastico
non avevo mai visto un posto come questo
e devo dire quando sono arrivato lì con
la mia valigia mi sono sentito da una
parte un po sfogo coltri korber ok il
mio laboratorio non era così avanzato
come l'apparecchietto di star trek
warhola il funzionamento doveva essere
abbastanza simile portava a livello di
principio un intero laboratorio di
analisi laddove spock voleva vedere che
organismo aveva di fronte
e poi mi sono sentito un po anche
indiana jones un indiana jones delle
rane perché ho dovuto affrontare delle
sfide notevoli e dei pericoli come
quello che vedete alle mie spalle per
riuscire a portare questo laboratorio e
mezzo alla foresta e ho dovuto
combattere contro contro animali
pericolosissimi ho imparato della verità
che quella che vedete le mie spalle una
vipera michele mi ha messo in mano una
vipera mi ha fatto capire che la bieber
avevamo paura di me e mi ha fatto capire
che molto spesso non abbiamo paura di
queste specie selvatiche che in realtà
non vogliono assolutamente farlo fare
del male a noi è che noi vediamo il loro
territorio però vedete che dopo tutto
non è così difficile neppure per una
persona di città come mai riuscire a
maneggiare un serpente come quello e
siamo partiti
siamo partiti siamo entrati in foresta
siamo entrati in foresta con una ventina
di persone che assistevano ho visto dei
posti veramente unici
avevamo le scimmie che saltavano da un
albero all'altro e sotto noi lavoravamo
per sequenziare questa piccola rana che
era una rana che probabilmente
rappresentava una nuova specie non era
mai stata descritta prima e l'abbiamo
fatto lì senza pareti senza aria
condizionata quindi senza energia
elettrica in condizioni davvero
difficili
l'ultima sera di notte lo vedete questo
momento in cui noi riesce
siamo finalmente per la prima volta
nella storia a leggere in mezzo alla
foresta il dna di un organismo selvatico
e riuscire ad associare il dna a una
specie da quel momento abbiamo iniziato
una serie di altre esplorazioni prima
con il muso e poi con tyson e spedisce
che è un associazione olandese che
organizza delle spedizioni negli angoli
più remoti del pianeta alla ricerca di
nuove specie perché considerate ci sono
8 milioni di specie su questo pianeta
ma all 80 per cento di queste sono
piccoline sono in fettine e adesso nuova
cercare gli insetti ne sono e spedisce
organizza questi viaggi insieme a comuni
e semplici cittadini che affiancano i
ricercatori nella ricerca di questi
insetti e uno dei primi effetti nuovi
che abbiamo trovato è stato questo
tuckson ha deciso di nominarlo grove e
linus leonardo di caprio per riconoscere
il contributo che leonardo di caprio sta
dando alla salvaguardia di quel poco che
rimane della biodiversità
cosa faccio adesso ho raggiunto il mio
obiettivo sono riuscito a portare questo
laboratorio in uno dei posti più remoti
del pianeta
anzi in diversi posti ormai più remoti
voglio continuare
a
a far scoccare le scintille c'era
un'altra che mi intriga in modo
particolare che allegata a questo
concetto vedete fino al secolo scorso le
grandi conquiste della scienza
consistevano riscoprire le cose oggi
invece soprattutto nel crearle allora
stiamo perdendo biodiversità e questo a
causa del della caccia del bracconaggio
dell'inquinamento ambientale della
sottrazione di terre che sono occupati
in questo momento da queste specie che
non sono più in grado di sopravvivere
cosa ci rimane rifiuta fare ci rimane
jurassic park un libro bellissimo molto
più bello il libro del film scritto da
uno dei miei scrittori preferiti michael
krypton michael crichton aveva
immaginato in questo libro di
fantascienza che un giorno saremo
riusciti a clonare i dinosauri
noi oggi superiamo la fantascienza di
michael crichton e ci accingiamo a
costruire gli organismi sintetici così
come noi siamo in grado oggi di
iscrivere i sistemi operativi dei
computer e quindi di avere degli
strumenti che fanno quello che noi
diciamo loro di fare oggi abbiamo la
tecnologia per cominciare a costruire
anche il dna e quindi il sistema
operativo degli organismi viventi questo
ci porterà molto presto a risolvere
problemi importanti come quelli legati
all'estinzione di numerosi animali
quello che vedete le mie spalle al
rinoceronte di sumatra ne sono rimasti
dodici esemplari non c'è abbastanza
biodiversità li perderemo lo sappiamo
perché non saranno in grado di
sopravvivere le malattie
ecco con questa tecnologia noi saremo in
grado di scrivere il sistema operativo
copiandolo dal rinoceronti ancora
viventi saremo in grado anche di
inserire delle piccole modifiche che ci
permettono di rendere questo rinoceronte
resistenti alle malattie
ora questo scenario potrebbe essere uno
scenario apocalittico alla jurassic park
dove noi portiamo in vita organismi che
si sono estinti
che è l'ambiente non è più adatto a loro
ora secondo noi è un controsenso cercare
di portare oggi in vita per esempio
anche solo l'uomo di neanderthal non
sarebbe adattato a un ambiente che è
cambiato troppo è una società che lui
non riconoscerebbe più questa cosa però
ha senso nel momento in cui invece noi
cerchiamo di salvare o di riportare in
vita quelle specie che sarebbero ancora
in grado di sopravvivere sul nostro
pianeta ma che semplicemente sono
scomparse perché le abbiamo distrutte e
cacciando le o perché abbiamo distrutto
il loro ecosistema potremo dare loro la
possibilità di ritornare
ecco io non so se questa è la soluzione
migliore però è l'unica soluzione che io
conosco e che sono in grado di
contribuire a portare avanti
l'alternativa è quella di scrivere una
cosa del genere sulle mie pagine web
grazie per l'attenzione
mi faresti
[Musica]